this closer look thing that you're doing
that seems to me like a Monumental task
how many guys and you are writing this
closer look I'm so glad you asked first
of all there's one guy who writes the
first draft his name is s Gentile he is
incredibly gifted and he came from cable
news he's also an a comedian as well but
he had worked a little bit and I think
that's what makes a closer look so
special is it's structured like a Cable
News segment it's got a a beginning a
middle and end he lays out a thesis he
comes to a conclusion
and he writes his first draft it's very
funny but it's especially incredibly
informative he works with a a wonderful
producer named Emily erus and the two of
them work together on it and then myself
and our headwriter Alex Bay we just go
through and take a pass at the jokes
this is fascinating to me how long is
this segment every night that you do a
closer look how long is it 10 to 14
minutes that's a lot of time in
television it's a lot of time and in the
10 to 14 minutes this guy s Gentile who
worked at C news but he's a comedian
which is weird he's the perfect guy for
this what did he do in cable news a
segment producer he that's what we
started with him he came in and he was
one of our guys who had when we had
political guests on our show he would be
the guy who would put together those
segments and he would be the guy who
would help me write the questions for
them and then the first few closer looks
I tried to write on my own and I had
clocked that sa was really smart and I
just brought him into my office he
wasn't even a writer on our show and I
would say hey does this at Le track does
this all make sense because I don't want
to I don't want to trip over my own feet
trying to make a point and S very often
would say actually you know this is
wrong and but if you said it this way it
would be right and it would prove your
point or at least you know make a better
case for it and so very quickly after we
brought him in a few times I said would
you like to be a writer and would you
like to be in charge of a closer look
and we that's amazing yeah and I mean
again in the beginning it was once a
month then it was once a week and and
pretty quickly you know we heard the
kind of lovely feedback that that you're
giving us it does feel like the part of
the the show that people turn up for and
uh and we do three out of the four days
a week that we do our show because we
are worried that s is going to die so
this guy when he sits down he reads
through the newspaper decides what it is
he likes the best and he puts together
the framework of what you're going to
talk about that night yes and I think
the other thing they do is they keep an
eye on clips that might be informative
to the point that you want to make
they'll watch the Sunday morning shows
and they'll realize oh you know Lindsey
Graham did this interview and and it's
really perfect for the point we're
trying to make and it's also funny look
we have people who can write jokes and
s's very good at writing jokes as well
the way he builds the it's like the
curtain rod that supports the jokes is
the thing that I've met so few people in
comedy that they can do because without
that 14 minutes of jokes is not as much
fun as people think it would be like you
have to have something underneath it
that has some nutritional value when
this guy hands you a script every day
and he says here's the basic bones of
what we're going to be doing and what
we're talking about you sit and read
this thing through and you're just
waiting for something to hit you you're
waiting for some kind of funny joke to
hit you yeah but it's so nice because
there's always nothing's worse than
staring at a blank page right that and
when I think back to
SNL that was the hardest thing in the
world somebody you know host comes in
and so you know all right Emma Stone and
it's this week and here's a blank piece
of paper and you know sometimes you
would just do weird exercises that
weren't helping I'm going to write down
all the cast members names now just to
see and they I'll be able to look at it
and see who can play what and so that's
the hardest thing in the world when you
read a first draft of a closer look
there's already this nice downhill
momentum now you almost feel like it's
like you're with a group of friends and
there's a conversation it's easier to be
funny with a group of friends because
often times you're just commenting on
something somebody said or you know it
becomes a back and forth so my writing
now is and again I'm not saying it's
easy but it's miles easier than it used
to
be